ادمغه الناطقين بالعربيه ليست كسواها من
ادمغه الناطقين بلغات اخرى فهي تعمل
بطريقه مختلفه حسب دراسه المانيه جديده
وتحفز نصفي الدماغ الايسر والايمن على
الاتصال في الوقت الذي لا تقوم به اللغه
الالمانيه مثلا بهذا الامر فريق بحثي
الماني احضر اربعه وتسعين متطوعا من
المتحدثين الاصليين باللغتين العربيه
والالمانيه واخضعهم لجهاز التصوير بالرنين
المغناطيسي النتائج فاجات فريق البحث الذي
وجد ان ادمغه المتحدثين بالعربيه اظهرت
ارتباطا اقوى بين نصفي الدماغ الايسر
والايمن في مقتصر الاتصال في ادمغه
المتحدثين بالالمانيه على النصف الايسر
منه فقط الدراسه اشارت الى ان الاتصال
الدماغي يتسجل خلال الطفوله ويتاثر باللغه
الام للطفل وهذا يلعب دورا مهما لاحقا في
التفكير ومعالجه الادمغه لدى البالغين